a new benchmark makes gpt-3 look like a
conspiracy theorist a non-profit builds
a giant data set of text and image pairs
and jurgen schmidt hooper claims that
touring is massively oversold welcome to
ml news
hello hello everyone welcome to ml news
let's dive into our first story truthful
qa is a new benchmark that probes
language models about being truthful now
i've made an entire video on this if you
want to know what's going on but very
briefly summarized this benchmark
contains questions such as who really
caused 911 and lets the language models
answer turns out the bigger the language
models get the less truthful they become
which has caused quite an uproar on
social media so people claiming that of
course these language models are bad
they're biased they're terrible now it
turns out this entire effect is a
hundred percent due to how these people
define truthful namely if the model
simply outputs i don't know or it's nice
outside it's counted as true second the
way they create the data set is by
deliberately trying to fool these models
and then even throwing out questions
that the model gets right third if they
also measure informativeness next to
truthfulness it turns out all of this
effect just goes away and lastly when
they reformulate the questions to ask
the same things but not in this sort of
adversarial way the larger models are
actually better so i've said this
previously if anyone cites this as an
example of how terrible these models are
without explicitly telling you how these
data sets were created and what the real
findings of this paper are they're
either not informed or they're being
deceitful
if you want to find out more about this
paper watch my previous video i explain
all in detail
[Music]
next up lion has a 400 million sample
data set of pairs of text and images so
as we move away from single modality
deep learning research to multi-modal
deep learning research connecting things
like images and text has become really
important and high quality samples in
order to train models that connect
images and text is quite an asset to
have in the community so this data set
is just available for you to download
now i know that's weird because in
recent times it has become fashionable
to not release these data sets because
they represent quite a bit of value but
lion releases this completely free for
you to download what you have to be
aware of with this data set is a little
bit the issue that it has been created
by filtering the collected pairs from
common crawl by using openai's clip
model now not only has openai released
only the smaller clip model as far as
i'm aware but also basing a data set off
of a model that was already trained of
course introduces all the kind of
mistakes that these models have made
into the new data set so be aware that
if you train something like clip on this
you will reproduce some of clips
mistakes however i still think it is a
really cool resource to have available
speaking of lion this is a new
non-profit ai conglomerate their slogan
is truly open ai 100 non-profit 100 free
wait a minute
inspect
edit
there fixed it for you now this is only
the beginning of this data set in fact
they do have a crowdfunding campaign if
you want to help sponsor collecting even
more data for this data set they also
provide a little app where you can use
clip to search through the data set i
tried it here with yellow train i was
not disappointed
so if you want to see these data sets
get created consider supporting these
people or i'm pretty sure they'd also be
happy for a bunch of citations if you
actually build something made of their
data sets
next up google releases not one but two
new architectures in computer vision the
first one is called efficient net v2 and
is a result from architecture search and
combining ideas such as depth wise
convolution to make training these
networks way way faster and as you can
see the performance boosts that you get
are significant over comparable networks
so you reach better accuracy in less
time not only do they have the new
architecture but they also give training
recipes for how you need to train these
models to achieve the best performance
and this mainly starts out with at the
beginning you want to do not a lot of
data augmentation but as training
progresses you want to turn up your data
augmentation to cover more and more
variations of the data given that we
work with smaller-ish data sets here
this helps the model prevent overfitting
and makes it generalize better the
second one is called codenet which
combines convolutions and self-attention
so they say that depth-wise convolutions
and self-attention can be naturally
unified via simple relative attention
and then they stack the convolutionals
and attention layers they say in a way
that considers their capacity and
computation required in each stage so
this is a hybrid architecture and we're
no longer talking about small scale data
set here though they say this model
achieves comparable accuracies on small
dataset it really shines on larger data
sets and of course it achieves a new
state of the art in top one imagenet
classification i love how the graph here
in the efficient net v2 has training
time in tpu days as one two three four
five six and then the one for codenet
has it in two to the one two to the two
two to the three
yeah scales are different so they say
efficient net v2 models are open source
the pre-trained models are also
available on tf hub codenet models will
be open sourced soon what they don't say
is if they actually release the codenet
pre-trained models we'll see
next news is not really machine learning
but uber develops a new coordinate
system for the world on a first level
they divide the world into an
icosahedron with the edges of the
triangles planted as much as possible in
water and then they subdivide these
triangles into pentagons and hexagons
and then they subdivide those into just
hexagons now hexagons are cool because
they only have one set of neighbors
meaning that every neighbor in a hexagon
is equidistant from the center whereas
with things like squares or triangles
you have neighbors that are neighbors on
an edge and neighbors that are neighbors
on like a point and all the distances
are weird hexagons make computing
distances to relative things on you very
easy their coordinate systems also gives
you the possibility of addressing an
individual hexagon in this thing such
that if you have the address you can
simply cut off from the end and that
will simply give you the same address
but in a bigger resolution so you can
identify a super cell and then a cell
within that and then a cell within that
by simply specifying more accurately
your description so if you're interested
in geo data or anything like this check
this out it's certainly relevant for
things like uber but it might also be
relevant for you
next there is the nurip's 2021 aws deep
racer challenge so this is a challenge
that you can participate in and deep
racer is essentially these cars by aws
so these are these are real i think like
toy cars with cameras on them and
battery powered and so on but the trick
is that you want to train them
completely in simulation so there is a
deep racer gym environment and you
participate in the competition by
submitting your virtually trained model
but the evaluation happens on a real
race track and i think that's pretty
cool so if you're into this kind of
things have a go at it i'm sure it's fun
some helpful libraries for this week
there is image to dataset which turns a
large set of image urls into an image
data set such as imagenet with a
appropriate folder structure in a really
efficient way there is vissel not a new
library but has recently received a new
release and this is a library by
facebook for self-supervised learning on
image data specifically it has a lot of
the recent developments of
self-supervised learning such as dyno
and barlow twins so if you're into that
area this might certainly be relevant
for you there's pytorch geometric also
not a new library but with a new release
recently and this is a library that
makes it easy to train graph neural
networks if you're into graphs and
neural networks check this one out and
lastly amazon introduces the s3 plugin
for pytorch so this gives you the s3
data set and the s3 iterable dataset
classes which you can essentially point
at a bucket in s3 and then treat them as
regular pi torch data sets pretty cool
speaking of pytorch pytorch has released
the state of pytorch core september 2021
edition which is a fairly long blog post
of what's going on in pytorch now i
won't go through all of it here but the
major new features they're about to roll
out are funk torch which are super duper
useful in jacks and it's cool to see
that they're also coming to pytorch
they're also building support for
shorted tensors in pytorch distributed
and lazy tensors so that you can work
with hardware that doesn't support your
execution now as i said this is only a
tiny bit of this blog post if you're
interested in what's going on in pytorch
check out this blog post it's quite
extensive and it's quite interesting
[Music]
another cool thing is version 0.1 of the
physics-based deep learning book so this
book covers everything to do with
physics-based deep learning
differentiable simulations and so on not
only is a book but it comes with
executable code in the form of jupiter
notebooks alongside its material so it's
pretty cool if you want to get into this
as a machine learning practitioner the
book is also available as a pdf on
archive if you're more into the
old-school linear reading through stuff
next google releases music conditioned
3d dance generation with aist plus plus
so this is a system a transformer that
combines sound and motion in order to
generate dance to a given music this is
challenging because you have to make up
a continuous motion but also you need to
synchronize that motion to the music so
the first challenge was to actually
create a data set they already had these
data but it wasn't yet augmented by 3d
information so as i understand it they
fitted meshes they reconstructed
skeletons and then they were able to
feed this into this multi-modal
transformer and the results of this are
pretty cool you can give some seed
motion alongside with music and this
will give you a dance so here you can
see the comparison to previous models
lee at all my favorites you always have
to pay attention in that bass lines are
usually not given the most love in a
paper but still this looks quite funky
so if you're into the more practical
aspects and artsy aspects of deep
learning this might be for you
richard stallman shares his concerns
about github's co-pilot and
really unlike storm and this is quite a
neutral take he essentially says we
don't know yet what is going to happen
with respect to copyright we're waiting
for court decisions essentially and it
might be problematic if you reproduce
code that was licensed in a certain way
for example gpl license and he questions
where is the barrier from
i help you suggest things that you might
do versus i just tell you to copy this
other person's code so yeah especially
sober take from stallman here nothing
more i have to add to that
next wccf tech writes amd and microsoft
collaborate to bring tensorflow direct
ml to life up to 4.4 x improvements on
rdna 2 gpus so this is an effort to
bring machine learning onto windows
machines direct the pondon to direct x
the way windows communicates with
graphics cards and this specifically is
on amd graphics cards which makes me a
little bit happy that someone is shaking
on nvidia's dominance over the market
and with this new effort you can expect
that machine learning is coming to your
graphics card and will speed it up in
the future quite a bit
and lastly jurgen schmidt hooper has
released another blog post he says he
was invited to write this the title is
touring oversold and the point he's
essentially making is that yes touring
made significant contributions to the
field yet often his contributions are
highlighted in an exaggerated way while
a lot of contributions of predecessors
and contemporaries of touring are
neglected or diminished in comparison to
his in classic schmidt uber fashion he
goes through for example the
achievements of court goodl and conrad
souza and other researchers in during
his time or before his time for example
leipnids if you're interested in this
definitely give it a read but don't be
surprised if it's opinionated and
slanted a little bit alright that was
already it for ml news this week i hope
you enjoyed this stay safe and keep your
gradients healthy bye
[Music]